l'actualité internationale les
etats-unis considèrent leurs opérations
frappe du désert en irak comme terminée
tous les objectifs ayant été atteint
certains des alliés de l'amérique ayant
émis des réserves sur cette initiative
le secrétaire d'état américain warren
christopher a engagé une tournée
d'explication en commençant par paris
bernard lebrun jean-françois flammes une
bicyclette tordus en tous sens un
propriétaire volatilisé des impacts
d'obus au coeur de la ville image
obligatoire et figure imposée pour la
première fois cette nuit les
journalistes présents à bagdad ont été
conviés à la visite guidée
et comme pour enfoncer le clou en exhibe
ses blessures bilan dans cet hôpital de
quartiers deux morts et 11 blessés
victimes supposées des bombardements
américains
si l'opération est terminée la polémique
commence entre les alliés de la guerre
du golfe sur l'extension du 32e 33e
parallèle de la zone d'interdiction reçu
cet après midi à l'elysée warren
christopher chef du département d'état
américain est venu convaincre la france
de soutenir cette extension on se
souvient que paris a tenu à marquer sa
différence au lendemain de l' attaque
américaine différence maintenu ce soir
la france ne s'associe pas au projet
américain et refuse que ses mirages
dépasse le 32e parallèle et puis il ya
les conséquences sur le terrain de cette
riposte américaine particulièrement au
kurdistan irakien
une fois de plus les populations civiles
ont fui les rues d'erbil la capitale
lentement mais sûrement l'étau se
referme au sud l'armée de saddam hussein
au nord les chars et la montagne turc et
c'est ce que danielle mitterrand qui
depuis treize ans avec son association
oeuvre au kurdistan a voulu dénoncer
aujourd'hui retrouvé les mêmes images
les villages les villages rasés les
populations d'époque déportés qui vont
faire dans les montagnes et qui vont
aller se réfugier où cette fois pendant
turquie et ils vont pas être parvenir à
l heure où vont-ils aller un nouveau
grand exode du peuple kurde
c'est ce que redoutent les organisations
humanitaires ces terribles images
c'était il ya cinq ans seulement au
printemps 1991